[Musik]
[Applaus]
störche für die beweglichkeit der us
gemacht das lied irgendwann irgendwo
gefunden hat auf das reagieren
[Musik]
ich glaube dass das nur aus jugend
bewegt ich bezeichnet aber drei
jugendbewegung
[Musik]
wir halten sodass der kranken und zürich
zum europäische sammelbecken von
krawallanten wir und sie macht das die
macher das schon richtig und damit also
das nicht groß hinterfragt
[Musik]
dass ich runter badenixe womöglich
versucht
[Musik]
willi schaffner heute hobbyfischer
damals polizeispitzel er begegnet in
diesem film einem der berühmtesten
aktivisten der bewegung
dessen auftritt dem fernsehen als herr
müller sorgt er 1980 für einen
landesweiten skandal überrascht
18 personen und gab auch und ich habe
nur wenig bekannt dass die drinks sie
sehen sich bewegten und eine nicht
unbedingt wieder begegne ich war relativ
einfach hier
der bruder schlaue die techniker mal
etwas schritt wird das nicht mehr heben
[Musik]
als barbara zu beginn der 80er jahre
nach zürich kommt ist die jugendbewegung
schon in vollem gang
elektrisiert von der kreativen energie
taucht die bernerin ein und engagiert
sich in der kultur und der frauengruppe
heute ist die bildende künstlerin mit
ausstellungen in der schweiz und dem
ausland ihre feministische haltung lebt
sie im büro und alltag
es ist total im nachhinein ich glaube
wirklich so als meint open und das ist
auf allen ebenen
er könne sich neu definieren wie werde
ich mich selber gestalten politisch
gender politisch sowieso künstlerisch
also das ist es das volk sie wo
ungeahnte möglichkeiten
das weiß gar nicht mehr wählen zustand
die stadt damals das ist stark sie
extrem verschlafen extrem verschlossen
und hinterm mond wie hütter klar ich
hatte ganztagestour ausgeschaltet und
die freizeit in der hand was der sie
damals konsumieren was gott das bisher
größte schau und die andere sender
vergönnt eine pause vom wannsee der
freizeitbus etwas mache dann sehe zu wie
der shop oder mal als kursbuch lassen
das wäre ein start erst zwölf ich glaub
ich tot sie das ist eigentlich durch die
provinz
fredy meyer alias herr müller gehört
1980 zu den treibenden kräften seiner
originalität und kreativität verdammt
die bewegung eigenwilliger aktionen also
in die geschichtsbücher statt aufbruch
und ja ich meine es ist im xf probieren
das glaub ich weiß eintracht aber so der
spanier machte bis man weiß aber gar
nicht wettmachen
erstmals seit einer 1980 gemeinsam im
gefängnis verbrachten nacht begegnen
sich aktivist und spitzel wieder
sie kehren an jenen ort zurück wo alles
begann schon seit jahren fordert zürichs
jugend einen freiraum als der stadtrat
1980 für das opernhaus einen
millionenkredit spricht bringt dies das
fass zum überlaufen von einem autonomen
jugendzentrum wollen die
verantwortlichen nach wie vor nichts
wissen
das mobilisiert viele jugendliche noch
im märchen die die skulptur der
konsumiere aus dem grund machen aktion
vor dem opernhaus in polizisten zum
schutz der zuschauer in stellung
gegangen
die stimmung ist aufgeheizt das ist
jetzt egal ob europa herstellen polizei
interessanter hieß damals heinz noch die
schilder katja krachte
ein behindertenheim soviel ich weiss
gemacht worden dass der ausdruck vorteil
ist okay jetzt gehen wir mal und ob es
so dass mit stars deine bilder wirkten
absicht sie das die demonstranten nahmen
baumaterial tappen sie wurde angeregt
und so zur blüte kratze sich es hat sich
ergeben wo aktiv verfolgen
es ist so kracht wissen und und
technisches abkommen
ich hab da sonst vor
[Musik]
das sind sofort los einzelne und dann
hat man natürlich darüber philosophiert
er was man auch tränen war ein voll
motorisierte polizist sieht nach die nun
schon seit wochen nicht geschafft und
sogar noch weniger verdient und auch der
beamtenstatus nicht kann
[Musik]
das haben forscher jetzt gesagt aber es
ist tatsächlich nicht so lustig sich mit
der politik unter druck
wir sind gegen eine mit hintersinn
physik ist der für ist ein christ aus
machen
[Musik]
und es gibt ja es gibt ja eine ästhetik
des widerstands oder und wenn man da nur
vergewaltiger sachen schrieb dann
vergisst man dass zum beispiel eines
anke auf der straße staut astor iv
das ist natürlich schön dass wir sie
schlagen mit oder das sind schaufenster
das hospiz liefern ein stückchen würde
ich nicht geplant ist
die bilanz dieser nacht hoher
sachschaden
45 verhaftungen und verhärtete fronten
der stadtrat ignoriert die forderung der
jugendlichen weiterhin verhandelt das
familienressort nicht respektiere
[Musik]
doch die jugendlichen lassen nicht
locker sie fordern vom stadtrat nun
ultimativ ein autonomes jugendzentrum
sie wollen eine konkrete zusage und
setzen der stadt eine frist straße
hinter dem carparkplatz welche sich im
besitz der stadt befindet ab kommendem
sonntag 12 uhr zur verfügung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
trotz der aussicht auf ein jugendzentrum
trauen die jugendlichen dem stadtrat
nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es folgen weitere demonstrationen der
druck auf den stadtrat wächst
also sehr brutal also so als linie fini
frau habe ich jetzt gleich behandelt
wurden wir so ein eis 80er kolleg im
hatcher extrem messe präsent und stark
sie wenn man sich dem ausgesetzt hat wie
weiter politik und polizei setzte nach
der ersten demonstrationswelle auf den
geheimdienst der plan beamte der
sondereinheit kk 3 sollen die
jugendbewegung infiltrieren
in diesem gebäude an der stampfen war
straße 63 tragen die verdeckt
operierenden polizisten insider
informationen zusammen willi schaffner
der 29 jährige polizist aus dem
urnerland wittert seine chance
er bewirbt sich als spitzel gc tritt
thomas kraus billige gleichzeitig wies
der 1 die mitarbeiter dieser abteilung
des christentums bildet jetzt nicht klar
muss vielleicht mit einer gemeint dass
ich fertig oder sich das geruchs regung
radwege woche also schlussantrag fast
zwei jahre kommen und du kannst einen
informationsmangel kann und dann einfach
die jüngste klappt ja kennen die michael
j
das ist der spruch sie können einmal
oder eine handcreme formationen sind tat
sie wenn ich was plant und so
wirtschaftlich total bevor trick sie
politisch 4x man sich unternehmer das
instrument machen
im kk 3 verwandelt sich der einfache
polizist willi schaffner in den spitzel
schaller willi
inklusive ausweis und undercover wohnung
an der badenerstrasse mitten in zürich
[Musik]
so sprachen die nun klar die wahl bauch
zur tarnung passt sich willi die szene
an er lässt sich die haare und einen
bart wachsen die spitzeltätigkeit ist
längst mehr als nur ein job sein
gesamtes leben verändert sich und führt
ihn an die rote linie und darüber hinaus
die rote linie beschrieb dreht sich mal
gewann sie es geschafft ich oder die
identitätskarte und volksnahe dass ich
sicher nicht wegen komplexer
das ist speziell school wenn man aber
eigentlich sei oder sich speziell an
sich nicht nachahmenswert ich hoffe da
kommt das noch doch forderung dass ich
bekomme das komische gefühl dass ich
nicht
das doppelleben hat seinen preis für die
damalige freundin tätlich die frischeste
mit lustig sehr berühmt geworden dass
grenzfrage ich bin heute richtung und
ohne sich sie jetzt interessant jetzt so
ist dann nach hause holt dass ich die
legendäre trio 60 prozent das war der
eingang die jungs okay war die jugend
unruhe sei in der ersten phase immer
dahin diene aber wenn natürlich denkt
sicher vv oder demonstrationen zu mehr
als 60 personen arbeiten während der
jugendunruhen im kriminalkommissariat 32
12 sind als spitzel im einsatz
der auftrag lautet aufrechterhaltung der
inneren sicherheit die aktivität der
politischen polizei steuert während der
jugendbewegung auf ihren höhepunkt zu
1000 fischen werden angelegt bis zum
fischen skandal im jahr 1989 beläuft
sich die zahl der fischen allein in der
stadt zürich auf 55.000 also das hängt
sache wo mir gemachten aufnahmen endlich
identifiziert und hätten die leute so
identifizierten barocke die stadt lenkt
ein
am 28 juni 1980 ist es soweit in einem
leerstehenden gebäude neben dem
hauptbahnhof zürich können sich die
jugendlichen ihren eigenen raum ein
bei der eröffnung des autonomen
jugendzentrums kurz- wird noch gehämmert
und geschraubt
emilie lieberherr die vorsteherin des
sozialamts macht sich vor ort ein bild
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was euer zeigte sich ja eigentlich als
biene russki wo sich alles drauf hat wo
mit der bürgerlichen struktur indexiert
und da hat es dir sprühender
intellektuell acker und die ursprüngen
der starterinnen künstler und was
natürlich schwierig sich dass ich
natürlich dann auch wirklich sie für
stans und drogenabhängige und dass ich
damals der stadt gar nicht so unklar
dass man dir da irgendwie versorgt hat
und quasi mir mit einem problem sind
kontrolliert sie das hat zum beispiel
ein eigenes forum k wo wir quasi die
leute an uhr betreut hat also hat die
ganz leer keine von ihnen kaputt oder
dass er zeit und auch immerhin kommt sie
das gleichgewicht halten zwischen der
konstruktiven und destruktiven treffen
[Musik]
das ajz hat auch ungebetene gäste
spitzel der stadtpolizei mischen sich
unter die besucher einer davon ist willi
schaffner extensiv im internet engagiert
was ich mir zuwider dass sie jene mische
ich nicht unbedingt optimal
also ich habe als zwiespalt ich will
hannes kratzen konnten
wo sich früher das ajz befand halten
heute fernbusse und reisecars willi und
freddy machen sich ein bild wo 1980 was
stand dann sind ist im vorderbereich und
darüber was im unterbereich da ich so
die großen also groß
nach einer vollversorgung mit
informationen über mettler was ich
beschlossen wurde in der regel zehn
abschlussaktion fonds mittlerweile
kommunizieren
jetzt treten die variante gehe unter
anderem der sogenannte patrick das heißt
wenn schwarz ich habe abgeleitet und
groß für mich aus dem lokal hat das
eingesehen kollegen horst seehofer nicht
und da hätte das gemeldet der zwei
tickets geister der wo es geht und wenn
man sich abarbeiten als kreis sei das
oxid petri zog das geht nur im sog das
ist kommunikation sei ihr wichtig will
der sache haben wir sowieso gar nicht
immer jetzt abgesprochen mit
handschalter moses informiert über für
mögliche verfahrenswege oder alles
sachen die zwei moment wo du sogar
verständnis für die gaga sieht der
polizei ich sage immer so ich bin jetzt
nicht so nachtragend
[Musik]
seinen posten und durchfahrende sorgen
macht sich der ort liegt so
[Musik]
die bewegung überrascht mit immer neuen
kreativen aktionen ein auftritt von
vertretern der bewegung sorgt im juli
1980 für einen der größten skandale in
der geschichte des schweizer fernsehens
diskussionen vor dem studio habe mir
einige lüthi klage ich darf mir
vorstelle links von mir zwei vertreter
von der jugendbewegung
ammermüller unter hans müller ja zu dem
auftritt disco in dem irgendwelche vom
fernseh ist grund hat der chinesische
markt
hättet ihr mit lust und rentier mit und
dann nachher mit kunde natürlich nein
und dann habe ich gemerkt das ist live
sendung aber schmidt von ebner okay so
der krieg der stadtrat trick der
polizeikommandant und so auch dass ich
die möglichkeit okay die güllener dt
wir machen genau das gegenteil wir sind
hier brachte die super bürgis wo zum
teil sogar schon einige sprüche
das verzerrt mehrheit hat der gefunden
okay er 2000 die ich und dann social
media the sun die kann ja weil man doch
nur was genau die jungen versuchten den
buchen und sind doch das alles ganz
natürlich wurden was mit brauchen die
stamme ich habe nur mit luft plädiere
ohne armee trümmermeer der
jugendbewegung ist und dann stand
revolution von anhalt 66 hat jemandem
vorgewagt wie die hinter mir wirklich
aus
der vorwurf liegt auf ihrer seite
dadurch gerade so richtig sagt ich meine
mit cent erhöht so habe ich mit ihr bei
der die damen und die herren dort jetzt
endlich nur benutzt um sich lächerlich
zu machen mit uns diskutieren
christoph gabel er die rektorin nach
gibt's umsatz und die zumindest mit
signatur mit war es für sache dass filme
mit wenige gummi trinken
das einzige was wir zu wenig sagte sie
sind auch gramm schwer war das ist im
letzten quartal aber mit seiner
gummiband gründlich haben wir doch nicht
so mit velo vertriebene in irland wo sie
in irland hat diesen dürfte so lang und
das sollte doch einmal darüber reden
dass sinnvolle sache
das ist so eine cb granada wo ihr da und
behauptet gibt diese krebsfördernd
hoffentlich ist hoffen die 50 fr serie
meinte jetzt ein herr rösler und herr
dann war der lage werde dann laufe ich
ihnen davon
ich finde das unerhört was ich wie beide
bietet das ganze gespräch zu beherrschen
wenn was passiert ich kein risiko mit
den behörden immer noch die in den
kommunen und wohngemeinschaft das album
weil über helfer ihrer demonstration
wird immer steigt dann keine weiße hai
und stadt war während der diskussion war
für sie ja kein dialog er plötzlich wir
danken wir mal an dritte nach dem
auftritt dass sie mit druck gesetzt und
zur zeit das ein toller wunderbarem ton
gefunden
das ist das was sie nie sein ding
dass ich aber rasant xii worum gehts
wieder wegzunehmen und das fernsehen
täglich stellt ja das ist ja gerade die
linke gesellschaft und so weiter
und ja dass ich danach redete nordsee
internen versteckt
dann hast du zwei tag sind dann als
imame also riesig ludmilla schnitt herr
und familie hansen donner müllers und in
der häuser namens inland wurde der passt
und das hat dann dazu geführt dass tat
ganz klar massiv mehr braucht also mit
mit mord ruhigen damals erfreulich dass
er es liebt das ist nicht gegangen
[Musik]
diese sind aktivisten xii wir sind dass
sie als frau fertig und das heißt dann
muss er etwas mit dem euer zeit sieht
man sofort davon frauen zusammen
hohenthann dies zur frau gruppe
zusammenschlossen und wir sind ja nicht
nur immer an der demo auf der straße und
dem herrn wirklich seriöse forscher für
sexualstrafrecht ist in revision und da
hat seine form vor entwickler und der
vorentwurf der heizung die spiel
beinhaltet dass murphy gewaltigen
straffrei macht wenn sich opfer und
täter kannten und daher natürlich müssen
die gegner hätte
[Musik]
wir sind also illegal unterwegs die wenn
man so will eine tolle energie aber
sicher immer nicht nun und die legalität
bewegen sondern sich alles mitgezogen
2008 haben kann in dem film sache
wohnhaus in der bedienung
[Musik]
herr stark gegeben abbruch sich unter
dem pflaster linke strand
nachdem sie mir freundinnen und ich
nackt auf die bühne und hat eigentlich
nicht anders zeit als eine viertelstunde
nachdem ob vorne und bitte euch leider
auch meine kumpel oder einen komplex und
mit honig weiter und dann laufen wir
denn
also ich kann den gips täter verletzt
wurde bin ich der erste noch von den
demos den hat so die dvag wo sonst außer
dir die striptease tänzerin und dann
sind tatsächlich die frauen unsere und
heimklatsche und riesenfreude und zum
einbruch zum verstoß ist jetzt auch
knallhart
okay sie immer nackt und gc - und so ja
die eintritt wenn man sich fragt warum
handelt je nachdem ob man macht den
handtücher gesagt das ist zum zeigen
nackte gewalt aus dem pädagogischen
moment und für uns hat es überhaupt
nicht auskommen einfluss zu machen
aus der boom fertig
nach der pensionierung zieht willi
schaffner zurück in seine heimat sei
2016 wohnt er mit seiner frau margrit in
gurtnellen hier nimmt er ein buch
projekt in angriff
über seine zeit als polizeispitzel
[Musik]
ich das für dich lag sie bis fotos
älteste salons viele kollege ziehen es
vor schwiegen die ganz ereignis hinter
sich zwar und minis graz sneijder im
sinn
das ist ein verständlicher
nachvollziehen wenn das nur wenn man
immer konfrontiert war damit bei mit der
russland im theater uri in altdorf steht
eine lesung an
schaffner bestreitet den abend mit der
autorin tanja poly die seine
erinnerungen in buchform brachte gefahr
besteht
die besteht die bestattung unterstellt
auf selektiver raubtiere das heißt eben
oder freundschaften schließt aber da
muss man aber aufpassen dass nur die
freundschaft fragt das ist also mir
darum geht welche mit anna lüth
kommuniziert wie die eigenen kollegen
item sind natürlich wie distanziert
dadurch dass er nicht verstand das ist
ein missbrauch der tat dass wir das am
missbrauch sie ihre miete zu sehen
die war immer dass ich gleich mehrere
bis ebenfalls für den staat hält dazumal
stunde mit musik machen und sagen sie
im sommer 1980 ist das ajz in betrieb
dennoch kommt zürich nicht zur ruhe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele jugendliche haben nach der ersten
ausschreibung welle ein strafverfahren
am hals 4000 demonstranten fordern dass
die anklagen fallengelassen werden
polizei und aktivisten geraten
wiederholt aneinander
[Musik]
die wendige dort oft noch als chance
dazu bietet das man dir dass die iwc
stehe ihnen eck gedrängt worden ist und
das müsse das wasser so anschaue hat wie
man da sagen die hat mir so machen
während der jugendbewegung werden fast
4000 aktivisten verhaftet in rund 1000
fällen kommt es zu einem strafverfahren
viele sind im krank ist sie und denn
sind neuen isolationshaft sie und die
breite masse im volk hat das ok gefunden
danach haben wir das komitee gegründet
gar keine solutions' haft maya dähne
quasi auch zeigt mir sind da es in nidda
jungen holen
also ich natürlich nicht so einfach sie
aber als mentale unterstützung ist sehr
wichtig nach einer polizei-razzia
schließt der stadtrat das ajz im
september 1980
die jugendlichen sind frustriert
wir sind die muse sind seit acht wochen
sie und mir einfach müssen nur mehr
versucht klar zu machen dass nicht
solche sache ist alle problem für euch
selber zu lösen wir sind ja problem von
der stadt
die erste bedingung ist dass man sie
nicht erleichtert sondern dass man hilft
verursacher die vor allem die probleme
bewältigen wohl nicht unbedingt direkt
mit judentums betriebs tour habe ich bis
mit bewältigung von drogen
problembewältigung von drogen machen die
jugendkriminalität und anlässen
erneut geht zürich jugend auf die straße
und kämpft für die wiedereröffnung des
ajz die gewaltspirale dreht auf beiden
seiten weiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist sowas auf und ab sie schließt
die gewitter umgang mit dem soccer city
fußarbeit sie sofort nach der
provisorische wieder heftig über das
stark ist wieder zum treffpunkt vor der
hackerszene wurde
fixe drogenhandel jugendliche auf die
kurve prägend atmosphäre die weniger wo
sich aktiv für die verbesserung gesetzt
hat resigniert immer mehr
die schlauen politikerinnen und
politiker die einflüsterer das
seinerzeit blieb dann zwei jahre nach
einem redet er besonders machen oder es
ist nicht wirklich drei torhüter morgen
kurz vor der bühne bearbeitet rucksack
schon gute teil von circa zerbrochen
im handstreich vom zürcher stadtrat bis
kurz vor der aktion kein kalten zu ruhm
das problem sei aber drogen und und die
ganze jugend zehn größten zieles zu so
einfach brice und fertig schluss und
verehren die ganze sieht hätten solche 2
[Musik]
es ist das einzige mal gelesen in der
höchster priorität der hersteller ohne
polizei löste in den usa 60 spekulation
süßen besetzen
[Applaus]
nach dem abbruch des ajz geht der
aufbruch in veränderter form und
zusammensetzung weiter
der antrieb und die energie der
jugendbewegung haben massgebend dazu
beigetragen dass zürich heute als
tolerante weltoffene stadt mit
kultureller vielfalt wahrgenommen wird
passend zu ihrer eigenen geschichte holt
willi schaffner fredy mayer in zürich
mit einem auto aus den 80er jahren ab
bei sich daheim in gurtnellen will er
den einstigen aktivisten hinein
geheimnis einweiht unterwegs reden sie
über gott die welt und natürlich über
die zürcher jugendbewegung
ganz wichtig ist dass die vorrichtung
für bronze vor der bund sein und so
geht's also liegt wo als amerika und ich
übrigens auch
es schenkt sich also wenn man tiere
mitbringen alte rosen und das so schnell
wissen
aus dem st das ist also subtropen achse
dixie wäre es mit patrick hat das auch
unipetrol wahrscheinlich braucht aber
mercedes stern ist speziell
dann geht das nur irgendwer mittelbach
ja ich habe mir das mit dem posten ganz
klar wie hecht die dich gefühlt also
bitte eine demonstration prosieben ich
schlage vor dass sie in glinde nicht
geschafft hat innere bank
das ist natürlich großartig politisch
ist das heißt sie mit 17 ist sind wir es
auch sind ganz klar politisch gesteuert
und tätig das ist ja dass sie sich
persönlich an steht wir haben brachte
gefunden und zum aus anteil hat einfach
ein achtungssignal woche passieren
nein so nicht oder
[Musik]
ja
und dann habe ich durfte
[Musik]
das gibt aber zwei mal genauer stoß zum
ja ja ja
[Musik]
sie mache darüber gemacht ästhetik und
die haben
[Musik]
wir fragen steht dienst eigenen fans
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
singen wie lang die bucht xi das heißt
strom eigentlich was müssen das heißt
den carport waage bringt sind erstunken
und erlogen der besten ist die benutzung
von öffentlichen luft wärme zum
politischen zwecken
da etwas dran smith mit seiner freundin
zusammen
dann ist im albert wurden schickt und
konnte den rat sind und straßen selbst
internet bin ich nix und faktisch 14
monika wo dann selbst rechtsanwalt und
und so liegt das ist es sie nix urteil
eigentlich
dadurch hat sich der angeklagte schuldig
gemacht erstens der fortgesetzten
einfachen körperverletzung da wiederholt
fortgesetzten sachbeschädigung der
vorgesetzten brandstiftung des wegen
landfriedensbruchs und drohung gegen
behörden und beamte zu bestrafen ist für
mich das entsetzen hat sieben und
diffusor bin
das sind nur nötig sie aber in denen ihm
eine tischdecke
zum tollen tipp wo genau kann das ist
nichts was mir weniger gut gegangen ist
besser und jetzt ist sie der boss bin
eigentlich sehr sehr bitter für eine 6
machen wieder also wider schrieben
wieder male eigentlich alles recht gut
gelaufen so hieß das hat mir grosse
probleme und dann irgendwann macht der
brechte trotzdem hat es für ihn ein
verhältnis ist alles anders
wir sind die nacht im büro xiii und
wurde wochen sie die linien damit
braucht hat plötzlich verschwinden
schnittig die augen vor allem familie
frau
auch im umgang mit dem das ist nicht
eine aufnahme situation
genau
[Musik]
das ist natürlich die dinge braucht
verschraubt und wo begegnen ja das gibt
es gar ein defizit ja ich etwas versäume
beaver creek war das einfach ist an dem
züri telefonate so wurde vier teams im
verknurrt aber es ist unwahrscheinlich
eigentlich musste garden hier um dich
gar nicht es fehlt also gar nicht nur
mit ihrer umwelt bis friedrichshain die
allianz und jetzt glaubt zu wissen wie
das ganze privat archiv verfügung der
zeit bis das sind so sachen das ist
zeigt das schwarz hat ja ich die
popgruppe ich war schon vage oder
ersetzen könne nicht allein im fokus
nachdem schwarz christen wir belastet
auch im innenraum
das wort sich hat der absolut die wissen
- anderer großer fisch aber hast du
durch bistro wo du gemacht hast
das ist zum beispiel dann bricht sie und
das ist also ruft sie vom informiert
dann werden auch sie auf ihre dass ich
hab gar geschlossen wurde von der einen
seite werden aufstand im kino xenix über
nicaragua die namen aber oft sind diese
nie registriert worden
aber weiß was ihr was sie brauchen wir
zur begriff vor zum beispiel wir
linksextrem es waren zum beispiel im see
nix im film läuft aus linksextremen film
beurteilt und auch ihr könnt lyko der
film nur dann sind das linksextreme das
ist praktisch zwei jahre jeden tag jede
woche zweimal aktionen gegen das areal
an der schwarza mein lied tokio singapur
sei dank ja die jetzt die ware
motiviertes oder sin city also dass ich
des staatswaldes dass die stelle ich sie
war womacka ist oder als das eigentlich
der job als ich meine jetzt also dass
ingo das sind ja eigentlich auch in der
regel nicht mit der pension als den
schritt
das j ich hoffe einfach gemacht
so wie ich es manchmal grenzwertig sie
aber ich hatte zunächst einmal gesagt
dass ich jetzt dort es sieht tatsächlich
da die akte aber die hämmert ist
stadtarchiv zu späteren auswertung wird
er trotzdem alles geschafft wie hätte
ihm seite funktioniert während die
vorgesetzte mit sind mit dem umgang und
so weiter dass ich recht begründen
am ende des ausflugs messen sich die
einstigen gegner in einem blog einzel
dem sogenannten peter t
wieviel überwindet das braucht niemand
schwerer zu begegnen wo man vor 40
jahren am spionierte eigentlich gar
keine windig ich finde das toll dass man
noch 40 jahre zusammen aber diskutiert
was damals passiert ist
iris gebeten da die nötig alles ist so
genannter social project nennt ehemalige
beweg dich fragt der film mitmachen
seien nicht wenige kam auf seiten der
spitze mit macht mache ich nicht mit
euro mehrstimmig gemacht dass ein teil
dieser funktion also polizist oder
spitzel so oder so kritische funktion
die kammer ausstellen die gerade wenn in
grau ständig machen und vor allem es ist
die schrecklichste 40 jahre also ich
werde das land wie eine erhalte k
gegenüber oder gehalten
mich interessiert das was der wille zur
zelle hat warum ist das sorgt auf was
ich hoffe ja also ich hatte auch kein
piigs 1 und setzte sprung
müsste eigentlich jetzt so alle haben
und eigentlich los ist jedoch wer hat
eigentlich die stadtwache tötet komplex
so sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]